y llegó la hora de hablar de economía en
Francia de 24 aquí en directo América de
edición nocturna esta noche con Juan
Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo buenas noches
para ustedes Buenas noches Ángela vamos
a empezar hablando de esta novelamos que
Twitter porque parece que ya se termina
cuéntenos Así es Ángela Pues el
multimillonario y los Moss propuso
seguir adelante con el acuerdo que había
firmado con Twitter para comprar la red
social por unos 44 mil millones de
dólares y decimos que pondría fin a la
larga batalla legal entre ambas partes
porque recordemos que Moss había pedido
a la red social como condición de compra
información del número de cuentas spam y
otros muchos requerimientos informáticos
después de eso desde abril ambas partes
se han echado culpas y han hecho más
peticiones legales con la noticia que
llega tan solo 13 días antes del
esperado enfrentamiento en el tribunal
de Delaware las acciones tanto de
Twitter como de la empresa de musk tesla
tuvieron importantes ganancias tesla
ganó un 2,9% registrando intercambios de
más de 27 mil millones de dólares en
acciones mientras que Twitter subió un
22% hasta alcanzar los 52 dólares por
acción si el acuerdo inicial de abril se
reanuda podría pasar que el sin sabor
quede para Twitter pues en estos casi 10
meses de la reputación de Twitter de
esta red social ha sido públicamente
criticada por elon musk incluso por
medio de tweets algo completamente
irónico acusaciones que tal vez jamás
sean revisadas en el tribunal bien en
otras noticias empiezan a disminuir las
ofertas laborales en Estados Unidos por
qué pues las empresas ya están menos
desesperadas por Buscar trabajadores
algo que en el fondo es una buena
noticia porque es lo que ha estado
buscando la reserva Federal enfriar la
economía el dato lo conocimos por el
informe de empleos del gobierno en el
que se reportó en agosto que habían un
poco más de 10 millones de vacantes
frente a las 11,2 millones del mes de
julio lo que representa una disminución
de casi el 10% en las ofertas de
vacantes de las empresas el informe
también mostró que los despidos se
mantuvieron históricamente bajos
recordemos que Estados Unidos también
Tuvo una temporada en donde el panorama
era completamente a la inversa las
empresas estaban incrementando su
salarios para hacer más atractivas las
vacantes y no habían personas
suficientes o mano de obra adapta Para
ocupar dichos puestos algo que en su
momento ayudó a disparar la inflación en
el país Juan Pablo el Banco Mundial dice
que la economía de América Latina
crecerá más de lo esperado este 2022
Ángel a la entidad dice que las
economías de la región ya se han
recuperado prácticamente a sus niveles
previos a la pandemia el dato se conoció
para América Latina y el Caribe y los
economistas del banco proyectan una
subida del 3% del producto interno bruto
en la región al finalizar este año un
número superior a estimaciones
anteriores impulsado por el aumento de
precios de las materias primas que se
exportan acá en nuestra región nuestra
rica región hacia otros países todo esto
en medio de la crisis que generó la
guerra en Ucrania sin embargo las
proyecciones para los dos años
siguientes no son tan positivas para
2023 el Banco Mundial prevé un
crecimiento de tan solo el 1,6% en la
región y del 2,3 para 2024 debido a que
se presume que los precios de estas
materias primas que estamos hablando
bajarán y para su cierre por favor Los
indicadores de la jornada Ángela pues
nuevamente las acciones volvieron a
subir bruscamente en Wall Street lo que
ha marcado el inicio de un mes positivo
luego de las constantes pérdidas del mes
de septiembre y mientras la economía de
Estados Unidos empieza a enfriarse como
lo decíamos ahora las bolsas europeas
siguieron la senda alcista de Estados
Unidos cerrando sus tres principales
indicadores con ganancias mientras se
espera que la Organización de Países
exportadores de petróleo anuncie mañana
un posible recorte considerable en su
suministro de petróleo en nuestra región
las bolsas cerraron en terreno mixto
luego de que la bolsa de comercio de
Buenos Aires cerrará con un pequeño
descenso del
0,09% frente a las ganancias de la bolsa
de valores de Sao Paulo y México pues
Juan Pablo del agradecimiento es para
ustedes para nuestros televidentes y yo
los invito para que sigan con nosotros
vamos ya mismo directo a la capital
estadounidense